now after almost seven years in the
Ecuadorian Embassy in London Julian
Assange was arrested this week and now
faces possible extradition to Sweden
where he's been accused of rape or to
the US where he faces charges of
conspiracy
the Home Secretary will have a key role
to play in his case and we're joined now
by one of his colleagues the energy
minister Craig Harry from her
constituency in Wiltshire hello thank
you for being on the program this
morning and Julian Assange has always
said that as soon as he left the embassy
then he would face extradition to the US
he's been proved right are you concerned
about what extraditing him would mean
well I'm not I don't think I'm gonna
comment too much on the kind of live
details of that case but clearly the
actual warrant for going into the
embassy was based on the extradition
request I know there are live legal
charges against him and we'll let the
legal process play out I mean he also
faces allegations in Sweden as well and
doesn't hear of rape and sexual assault
as well it seems as if Oh while the US
and Ecuador were aware that the arrest
was going to happen Sweden wasn't
actually aware but if they do submit an
extradition request do you think that
should take precedence over the u.s. oh
gosh you're assuming I know that the ins
and outs of the law I mean again I'll
let Sergey Joe must have an opinion so
whose issues well I think it's my
opinion is that here's a gentleman for
whom there are pending legal inquiries
who's been able to seek asylum and also
not be a particularly delightful
houseguest by the sound of it and the
process of the law has caught up with
him and it will you know deal with him
as appropriate but what's your view
though do you think that he should face
the charges that were not charges but
face the allegations that were brought
in Sweden absolutely I mean if you have
you know this has been part of the
challenge I think that the two long
allegations of sexual assault or rape
have been rather dismissed and we've
seen in the last few years that they've
actually quite rightly been taken
seriously and so the courts will decide
the validity of those of those
challenges and then as to who takes
precedence in the overall extra
to say I'll let the I let our excellent
judicial system decide that okay well
let's move on to some other issue shall
we I had bright setting off a father
away according to you a poll of polls in
The Sunday Telegraph if there was an
election now then labour would be the
largest party Jeremy Corbyn would have
the keys to Downing Street and according
to the president of the British polling
council it's because of the government's
failure to deliver brexit are you
worried that the Conservative Party are
going to be punished for the fact we
haven't nothing yet yes and I was
listening carefully to what Ian Duncan
Smith was saying and I think he's
absolutely right that I think there is
such a sense of frustration that we
wanted to be out by March the 29th we
could have been out and the reason we're
not out is that a number of colleagues
were long colleagues in my party on both
sides over hard over on leave hard over
on remain plus the opposition couldn't
support what I think is a perfectly
acceptable divorce agreement if you like
the withdrawal agreement and it's just
so frustrating and by the way and that
chance is still this although we've had
the extension which none of us wanted if
we can pass the withdrawal agreement a
withdrawal agreement in the next three
weeks then we will be out and we won't
be fighting the European elections and I
agree it seems it seems really silly and
daft to be doing that when the
opportunity to not do that is absolutely
in our grasp but yet but I was listening
very carefully to what Ian said and was
he invited for the withdrawal agreement
as I did I voted for brexit at every
opportunity and the challenges I think
we have to face the world as we find it
not as we would want to see it and you
know we have a an acceptable pragmatic
withdrawal agreement we also have a
parliament that wouldn't support No Deal
it's made that very clear in
constituencies like mine you can see
I've met they make the sheet maybe in
shocked you know this is an agricultural
constituency whether we hear whether
we're in Cumbria whether we're in the
West Midlands we have listened to
businesses and the and the millions of
jobs that they create who have said a No
Deal brexit is completely unacceptable
and Ian talked a lot about the backstop
very knowledge
the backstop in my view will never be
triggered because it's been absolutely
clear that both the UK and the EU want a
future trading relationship so I think
what's really important is that we you
know it's Easter there's a chance to
slightly reflect in the sunshine of
what's been happening it's been an awful
fractious divisive time parties like the
brexit party to me are just an absolute
blast from the past and what we should
be doing is looking for areas where we
can come together and create common
ground and deliver brexit and then talk
about the stuff that really matters
you know we're discussing with all this
energy and passion and pain our future
relationship with Europe over the next
18 months two years what I want to be
talking about is what's happening with
the climate - what are we going to do to
move to a green brexit that's entirely
within our grasp create those hundreds
of thousands of jobs in the low-carbon
economy and continue to be a world
leader in cutting carbon emissions so
you know I think all of us are glad not
to not to be in Parliament this week but
we have to be using this time to reflect
on how we actually come together rather
than looking for ways to move further
apart so you're talking about the
divisions got people moving further
apart and our first interview this
morning was with Alice uber who was
saying I heard yes she simply doesn't
really feel as if she can be a member of
the Conservative Party now because it's
the party that's changed not her as she
says she looks at people like Boris
Johnson like Jacob Riis morg like Martin
Francois and feels like she has more in
common with MPs like chakram you know
and leshawna bersia I mean do you
understand where she's coming from I do
and I also understand Anna who has been
a passionate conservative I mean for
decades and it was she's a real loss to
the party it's always really sad when we
lose colleagues from all side of the
political spectrum but you know the the
Conservative Party has always been a
really broad coalition we you know Ian
will tell you about that the debates
that happened over Maastricht and how we
manage to keep wonderful people like Ian
and also Ken Clark in the party so is it
becoming less broad successful no well I
don't think so I think what's happening
is because brexit was not a party line
vote and it breaks it absolutely divided
the country right down the middle and
I did both political parties right down
the middle and what we've got to do is
say well seven out of ten of my
colleagues including me represent a
constituency devoted to leave but six
out of ten at the neighbor party MPs
represent leave constituencies we have
to find that common ground and deal with
brexit which is a very specific in my
view non party issue because there you
know we're all Democrats we sit in
Parliament across party as Democrats and
should be focused on delivering that
that referendum result but what joins us
as a party is our values is our desire
to build a future where everyone can get
along our desire to have a well-balanced
economy so we can invest in public
services those values are still
completely intact and that's why I
remain perfectly comfortable in the
Conservative Party albeit really keen to
get through this period of dissent and
turmoil which is not pleasant for
anybody and focus on the future we've
got another six month delay another
sizable delay Shiprock so you were
saying there that you don't believe this
any parliamentary majority for No Deal
honestly do you think there is now a
chance that we might not actually leave
the EU no I don't I mean I think also
it's that there's a pretty clear
parliamentary majority to not have a
second referendum of any sort and also
not to revoke and look honestly speaking
I mean I campaigned to remain I have
absolutely accepted the result of the
referendum I I've described myself now I
think as a sort of moderate brexit ear I
can see the opportunities that are out
there from brexit and I think so many of
us feel that in Parliament so to me we
were sent there to do all sorts of
things including deliver this brexit
result it will be a real abrogation of
duty of MPs to say well we can't decide
so we'll pass all these really
complicated questions back over to two
people watching at home so they can
really agonize about brexit for the next
few years I don't think so I think
breaks it will happen you know we're so
close to getting this this withdrawal
agreement the divorce agreement over the
line we just need people to focus on
coming together and compromise and I
think actually you know when I go out
around the country
say why are you not working together to
solve this and as much as I agree with
you and I think Jeremy Corbyn would be
an absolute disaster as Prime Minister
but I know that the values of the Labour
Party when it comes to brexit you know
they want to get out many of them that's
what that's what most of that bag MPs
represent his leave seats there has to
be common ground and the first rule of
politics by the way it's have you got
the numbers and we have to get the
numbers okay now a quick one because I
mean told him I hear that I've got to
wrap you but I am cakes please one more
cheeky one into the interview and the
climate change protest group extinction
rebellion planning two weeks of protests
to focus on climate change obviously
they're the ones if you recall who
stripped off in the public gallery in
the heights or you met with them in
November what did you make of them well
I'll meet with anybody who's passionate
about solving the crisis of climate
change and so I'm not gonna accept any
people so why did you meet them because
I'm really interested to meet with
anyone but but I have to say as I told
them then what I'm interested in is
solutions not tactics that are
incredibly disruptive and I'm afraid
that the solutions they had there
weren't any it's just you need to
declare a war well I already think we've
we've we've declared a war on this it's
become a fundamental part of our
government policy that we continue to
reduce our emissions we've led the world
in cutting our carbon emissions mrs.
Thatcher was the first person that ever
talked about man's impact or humanity's
impact on the climate so what I'd say to
them is we hear you loud and clear there
is no need to create mayhem for millions
of people to get your message across
let's focus on the solutions that we
need to deliver how we're going to catch
a carbon from heavy industry how we're
going to sort out transportation how
we're going to develop alternative fuels
so that people can continue to fly which
is an important part of economic
activity without further pollution I'm
interested in solutions I think we need
more solutions and less protests